[Music]
we hold these truths to be self-evident
that all men are created equal in what
are they created equal is it in size
strength understanding figure moral or
civil accomplishment or situation of
life every Plowman knows that they are
not created equal in any of these all
men it is true are equally created but
what is this to the purpose
it certainly is no reason why the
Americans should turn rebels because the
people of Great Britain are their
fellow-creatures ie
are created as well as themselves it may
be a reason why they should not rebel
but most indisputably is none why they
should they therefore have introduced
their self-evident truth either through
ignorance or by design with a
self-evident falsehood since I will defy
any American rebel or any of their
patriotic retainers here in England to
point out to me any two men throughout
the whole world of whom it may with
truth be said that they are created
equal that they are endowed by their
creator with certain unalienable rights
but among these are life liberty and the
pursuit of happiness the meaning of
these words that Congress appears not at
all to understand among which are life
liberty and the pursuit of happiness let
us put some of these words together
all men are endowed by their creator
with the unalienable right of life how
far they may be endowed with this
unalienable right I do not yet say but
before I do these Gentry affirm to
themselves an unalienable right of
talking nonsense
was it ever heard since the introduction
of blunders into the world that life was
a man's right life or animation is of
the essence of human nature and is that
without which one is not a man and
therefore to call life a right is to
betray a total ignorance of the meaning
of words a living man I am an with life
have a right to a great many things but
to say that a man with life has a right
to be a man with life is so purely
American that I believe the texture of
no other brain upon the face of the
earth will admit to the idea whatever it
may be I have tried to make an idea out
of it but I admit I am unable prior to
my having any right at all as a man it
is certain that I must be a man and it
follows a man I certainly cannot be if I
have no life and therefore if it is said
that I have a right to life then the
word I must signify something without
life and consequently something without
life must be supposed to have a property
which without life it is not possible it
can have but they say all men have not
only a right to life but an unavailable
write the word unalienable signifies
that which is not alienable and that
which is not alienable is that which
cannot be transferred so as to become
another's so that their unattainable
right is a right which can
transfer to a broomstick or a cabbage
stalk and because they cannot transfer
their own lives from themselves to a
cabbage stalk therefore they think it is
absolutely necessary that they should
rebel and out of a decent respect to the
opinions of mankind alleged this as one
of the causes which impels them to
separate themselves from those to whom
they owe obedience the next assigned
cause and ground of their rebellion is
that every man hath an unalienable right
to Liberty and hear the words as it
happens are not nonsense but then they
are not true flaws there are in America
and where there are flaws their liberty
is alienated if the Creator hath endowed
men with an unalienable right to Liberty
no reason in the world will justify the
abridgement of that Liberty and a man
have a right to do everything that he
thinks proper without control or
restraint and upon the same principle
there can be no such thing as servants
subjects or government of any kind
whatsoever in a word every law that has
been in the world since the formation of
Adam gives the lie to the self-evident
truth as they are please determine
because every law divine or human that
is or hath been in the world is an
abridgment of man's liberty their next
self-evident truth and ground of
rebellion is that they have an
unalienable right to the pursuit of
happiness
the pursuit of happiness is an
unalienable right this surely is out
doing everything that went before put it
into English the pursuit of happiness is
a right with which the Creator have
endowed me and which can neither be
taken from me nor can I transfer it to
another did ever any mortal alive hear
of taking a pursuit of happiness from a
man what they possibly can mean by these
words I admit is beyond my comprehension
a man may take from me a horse or a cow
or I may alienate either of these from
myself as I may likewise anything that I
have but how that can be taken from me
or alienated which I have not must be
left for the solution of some unborn
Oedipus
[Music]
you
[Music]